We are once again partnering
with our good pals at AT&T
this time to bring you a one hour pre-show
live from the roof of the
glorious Spreckels Theater.
It's called Conan 360 Live.
It is broadcast entirely in
360 degree virtual reality,
and hosted by very funny comedians
Chris Redd and Moses Storm.
Andy's wearing a VR
headset so we can say hi.
Do you see Chris and Moses, Andy?
I do.
There they are!
They're right in front of me,
it's like I can touch them.
[Conan] Yeah, they're
on the rooftop right now
and I think there they are.
Yes, yes.
(audience cheering)
Hey Conan.
Hey, I don't know where I'm at.
This is beautiful.
Yeah, it's beautiful.
What a sad set we built for them.
(audience laughing)
Conan do you like our set?
Yeah, it's a rejected
outhouse from Jurassic Park.
It's really more of an encampment.
[Conan] I know.
We're sorry guys, but
you're doing a great job,
and guess what, our Conan 360, oh look,
there was some AT&T signage there.
Andy, don't accidentally
look down and see that.
Oh my goodness.
[Andy] Where are my legs?
(audience laughing)
They took my legs!
Guess what, our Conan 360 Live pre-show
has three other cameras.
We got stage door.
That's right, stage door.
There it is, yeah pretty amazing.
(audience cheering)
You don't see that every day.
Turn around Andy!
[Andy] You don't know it
but you're on TV right now.
[Conan] We've got inside the theater!
Yes!
(audience cheering)
That's the lobby.
I guess that's the lobby,
and we have the audience area
right here where the stage is.
Let's see that so we
can the next (mumbles).
(audience cheering)
Where are they?
oh yeah.
My legs are still gone!
You're legs are still there.
(audience cheering)
You can watch,
you look like a fool,
you can watch
(audience laughing)
as opposed to me in a this suit.
You can watch the VR pre-shows
on our team Coco Facebook,
YouTube channels and at teamcoco.com/360.
Thanks to our pals at AT&T.
We'll be right back.